hanck grammarians today we're going to
talk about three of the relative adverbs
in English which is where when and why
and this over here is Peggy the dragon
and we're going to use the story of
Peggy the dragon in order to figure out
how to use these relative adverbs you
may be looking at these words and
thinking that they look an awful lot
like question words and you're right
they are these are question words but
you can also so you can use them to ask
a question like where are you from
because we use the word where to figure
out where stuff is in space so you know
where figures out place so Peggy could
respond and say that is the cave where I
grew up and you can see that where here
is not being used in a question way it's
actually connecting the the clause I
grew up to cave and this is why we call
this a relative adverb because the word
where modifies the word grew it's I grew
up where and it also connects this whole
thing to cave because where did Peggy
grow up a cave and it connects this
whole chunk to the rest of the sentence
to the sentence being that as the cave
we use the word when to ask questions
about time so if I asked Peggy you know
your dragon when did you learn to
breathe fire because all dragons can
breathe fire she would say I learned to
breathe fire when I was ten years old so
again we're using this word when to
connect these two ideas when did she
learn to breathe fire when she was 10
years old and technically when is an
adverb that modifies was finally we use
the word Y to figure out reasons for
doing stuff so if something strange were
happening in the countryside and I asked
Peggy oh mighty dragon do you know
why it is raining fish Peggy could say I
don't know why that's happening so again
we've got these two clauses that is
happening and I don't know and why
connects and relates them and why is
modifying is happening here and there
are other relative adverbs like while is
another way to say when and whence which
is archaic and nobody really uses it but
it's another way to say where and if
you're familiar with Romeo and Juliet
from Jake's beer you've probably heard
the the word we're for you know as in
Romeo Romeo wherefore art thou Romeo
deny thy father refused the name etc and
that's an old-fashioned way of saying
why so we don't really say we're for
anymore we don't really say whence
anymore
but while is another way to say when
we're you asked about place when you
asked about time
why is for reasons these are the
relative adverbs of English you can
learn anything Dave it out